brexit with each passing day it's come
to mean a more dis United Kingdom and a
more damaged weaker government my guest
this week here in London is Bernhard
Jenkin a leading brexit campaigner and a
Conservative MP how did Britain get into
this crisis and how's it going to get
out of it
[Music]
meda jenkin welcome to Catholic sir last
summer you said if there's a deadlock in
British politics it's usually resolved
with a general election and if
Parliament is determined to block brexit
to resume we'll have to take the
decision back to the people in the form
of a general election why aren't you
pushing for that now it's high time
isn't it that's the usual conventional
view of British politics first of all
there was already a general election
since the referendum but you put this
forward last July yes I did but what I
was saying was that's the usual way of
resolving this what's wrong with that
now are you afraid of losing
well I that it I honestly don't think
now would be the right time for a
general election because the we are so
close to the 29th of March deadline
which could be extend and what's more
Parliament has already legislated
democracy has been served for the United
Kingdom's to leave the European Union on
the 29th of March with or without a
withdrawal agreement but that question
is by act upon but this could be altered
by Act of Parliament this would be very
unusual you claimed last week that the
Prime Minister despite the political
defeat the large huge political defense
she suffered was now in a very strong
position to go back to the EU and tell
them to change the agreements so that
it's acceptable to the House of Commons
very strong position really having
suffered the worst defeat of any
Palestine House of Commons history but
look what's transpired over the weekend
the Prime Minister seems to be going
back to the European Union invited by
Angela Merkel no less who has said that
50 years from now it would look very
strange if we didn't look back and say
well why couldn't they find a compromise
and I think some kind of compromise is
what she needs to find and a compromise
that could bring the DUP back on board a
compromise that would bring a large
number of conservative MPs back on board
is still a possibility and I would
invite Angela Merkel to
our offer to be compromising why should
they look again in the deal when it said
they've already said this is the only
deal on offer so that you can come back
again in a couple of months and try to
alter it again well I mean there's been
no consistency from the British side has
I don't think the British side has
negotiated particularly clearly and I do
to some extent sympathize with our
European partners that Teresa Mayer's
government hasn't been very clear
because of internal divisions within the
within the government Parliament has
legislated that we're leaving on the
29th of March now
Parliament's being clear about what it
doesn't want us to be clear about what
it does want
well Parliament is so far rejected that
withdrawal agreement but it hasn't
rejected the leave date of the 29th of
March and it remains to be seen whether
it does so but to the EU there's very
little point in negotiating with someone
who manifestly does not have a mandate
for the deal she's already agreed let
alone anything else in the future well
she has a mandate as as does the House
of Commons as a whole to leave the
European Union to fulfil the referendum
result and as I keep repeating the law
is now quite clear in the United Kingdom
and indeed in the European Union we're
leaving on that date now there are
people in the House of Commons who are
trying to change their decision change
the decision of Parliament they are
assuming that the European Union will
automatically provide some extension to
article 50 I imagine the European
Union's going to want to ask what for
why are you extending article 51 of the
draft proposals extends article 50 for
nine months do you really want the
United Kingdom to take part in the
European Union elections to the European
Parliament when we're planning to leave
the European Union just nine months
later tell your sympathies are suddenly
with them let's see well I'm I'm I'm
endeavouring to be understanding of the
difficulties that were facing
but the I keep repeating the part of our
Parliament has spoken and legislated
both main parties were elect
on the basis of the triggering of
article 50 which set the date for the
29th of March and that is now
implemented in law you've been saying
that No Deal is increasingly attractive
but that's not what you and your vocal
Eve colleagues promised the country was
it I mean time and again they promised
great deals with the EU and everyone
else and said they they just fall into
Britain's lap didn't they turned out to
be nonsense well I have to confess that
I think it's in the European Union's
interests to strike a sensible
free-trade deal with the United Kingdom
and whether we make that agreement
before we leave which looks rather
unlikely now or after we leave I believe
that that's what will happen but in the
end my point is that we need broken
promises weren't well where the vote
leave campaign didn't make promises we
were campaigning where your fellow
brexit err and an erstwhile brexit
secretary David Davis constantly boasted
that both Britain's exit terms and a new
free trade agreement would be wrapped up
within the article 50 timeframe that
hasn't gone so well he said at the end
of two years soon in 2016 in the end of
two years he said we will have our deals
you don't have well I think there was
definitely overconfidence there but I
think it wasn't helped by the fact that
Theresa May couldn't bring the cabinet
together to agree what they were going
to ask for and then in and then started
asking for a much more complicated
arrangement than I think that president
tusk was originally offering at March
last last year and then the whole our
Irish border question has been
conflicted as a mechanism to try and
split the United Kingdom which in a way
that's completely unacceptable I don't
know why the Prime Minister ever
accepted the premise of that discussion
in 2017 the International development's
actually old Fox told the country we're
going to replicate the 40 EU free trade
agreements that exist before we leave
the European Union so we've got no
disruption of trade believe me believe
me he said we'll have up to 40 ready for
one second after midnight in March 2019
now he says he's only confident about
five
false promises or well it's lousy
prediction they are the most important
five including Switzerland and Norway
but the the reason why other countries
are not ready
we already the reason why other
countries are not ready is because they
are convinced by all the propaganda that
were not going to leave on the 29th of
March
why wasn't any of that risk factored
into these brave new world promise I
think you'll find the government's
positions being made very much more
difficult by a large number of MPs
saying they support the result of the
referendum and want to implement it and
then they're being doing their best to
be very obstructive and and to be unkind
so this this is project fantasy on the
part of the leave campaign wasn't it I
mean like David Davis's promise in 2016
that the first calling point for a
British negotiator won't be Brussels it
will be Berlin to strike the deal
absolute access for German cars and
industrial goods in exchange for a
sensible deal on everything else what's
worse the fact that that didn't happen
or the fact that he simply had no idea
that individually you members can't
negotiate bilats world
I wonder if Angela Merkel is being is
beginning to be a bit worried that the
EU has been allowed to overplay its hand
because if the EU thought it could take
the United Kingdom captive in these
negotiations it's finding that that is
not the case but you're not addressing
the fact that the British political
landscape is littered with these broken
promises I don't have set their voting
promises I expect that the main promises
that we would leave on the 29th of March
and we will need leave with all the
deals that would be the easiest deal in
history to acquire if we leave on the
29th of March I have a no doubt that
those those free trade agreements that
he who has with other countries will be
novated very quickly in order to
facilitate trade between the United
Kingdom and those countries but there
was a lot of ignorance on the leaf so it
wasn't there I mean even among some of
the most visible campaigners like Boris
Johnson for instance when he was
questioned on TV last September turned
out he didn't know that Switzerland was
in the single market and refused to
accept it when he was told that was the
case I'm not responsible for what
the the we voted to the cheerleading
brexit own you hear this sort of
nonsense come out why don't you say this
is wrong
we're British people deserve the
referendum result to be implemented it
deserved you told them I some they
deserve the truth and they don't deserve
a whole lot of MPs who say they accept
the referendum result and are now
campaigning against it and you know I do
advise our European partners not to
overplay their hand they were that we
the United Kingdom is becoming more
likely by the day to leave on WTO terms
which means it doesn't mean we leave
without agreements the European Union's
already made preparations for a WTO
brexit for the United Kingdom and some
some yes and there are other issues to
be resolved but in the end I still
believe that Mercedes and BMW will want
to send sell their cars to the United
Kingdom tariff free but if we need to
charge tariffs on their on their
vehicles so be it well they've been very
quiet about that haven't they you've
expected the Titans of German industry
to come forward and support your line
but they haven't done that and have they
well it's quite clear that in Germany
the European Union is seen by the
hierarchy as more important than
anything else more important than German
jobs more important than German trade
with the United Kingdom I have to
confess I'm a little bit surprised by
that but that's a matter for Germany but
but you all you need to do is listen to
what they've said I mean this was from
the industry group with the German
industry group with the BDI some seven
and a half percent of German exports go
to the UK big number but ninety two
point five percent goes somewhere else
so as much as we'd like to uphold good
relations with British customers it's
extremely important for us not to
alienate other European markets a valid
concern isn't it if that's the way they
want to look at it but I would hope that
doesn't surprise you well it doesn't
surprise me because Germany is has a
very United political culture and is
very in favor of the European Union and
as the article 50 process has been
progressing we've seen the rise of AFD
in Germany we've seen the rise of other
right-wing parties across that going to
do
their attitude makes it makes to reverse
it it makes the European Union looked
like a very fragile political project
with very tender and vulnerable
credibility with with populations in
other European countries happily we
haven't got a right-wing party in this
country because our parliamentary system
tends to absorb those political and
economic shocks and yet but I would call
so popular in the member countries then
it's been in the last thirty well let's
see let's see what's happened initially
for example where they were elected a
very anti EU government that looks set
to a division just back down over its
budget problems with with Brussels and
you think that's going to lead to peace
between the Italian government and the
and and Brussels and the body you're
saying it's going quite a wall I suspect
it will lead I suspect the the eurozone
in the end will break up because it's
unsustainable that's a big claim and
that's a big claim let's look at this No
Deal prospect that you think is becoming
more and more attractive the warnings
from the head of the WTO himself Robert
Aceveda said last summer that other
countries would look to take advantage
of the UK's position complicating or
preventing agreements on some points the
moment that other countries he said
begin to sense an opportunity to
increase market share or increase the
quota here or there they're going to go
for that there'll be a lot of
uncertainty a lot of unpredictability do
you not give any validity to these
warnings well I think we live in a
globalized world where there is intense
competition between different member
states the WTO and here's reflecting
that element of uncertainty but given
that most of the world conducts most of
its trade on WTO terms or agreements
concluded under the WTO framework it's
not unreasonable that the United Kingdom
the sixth largest economy in the world
should avail itself of that framework
and seek to do agreements with other
countries on that basis at the end of
October some 20 countries including
Russia were reported to be looking to
squeeze their own commercial advantage
from brexit this after they'd blocked an
attempt by Liam Fox to fast-track a WTO
deal on the UK's terms well so the
blocking mechanisms already coming over
in the WTO
which you seem to think is going to save
a from the answer all our problems I
think to describe the WTO it's the
savior of all our problems it does
represent a safe haven a safer Haven
than probably the withdrawal agreement
they were being offered at the moment
and to that extent it would be
preferable
I repeat most countries are not in the
European Union they're not in customs
unions they trade across customs
frontiers and they have trading
arrangements with other countries which
they agree on a bilateral basis or they
own draw a joint international trading
arrangements and if you listen to the
Japanese ambassador the other day on BBC
News he was talking about yes their
inward investors would prefer us to stay
in the single market in the customs
union but he described going on to W
terms as quotes no better than a customs
union of course the Japanese car plants
in this country import quite a lot of
their just-in-time supply lines from
outside the he did say a bit more
actually on that interview he said if
it's just straight to WTO which Japan
has been trading on with a number of
countries that means that the way they
do trade is not the most effective
efficient frictionless way of
manufacturing that they are used to here
in the UK and you can't change it
overnight they say this was pretty clear
that they're used to they're used to it
trading in the UK they will adapt I mean
I visited the Honda plant in Swindon
recently where they make the five-door
Civic okay they make the engines there
they assemble the vehicles there some
50% of the added value of that car is
imported from outside the EU just in
time supply lines crossing crossing
customs frontiers crossing WTO frontiers
it's not impossible the Japanese
ambassador went on to say that the
procedures will have to be in place and
therefore some companies will have to
suspend operations not forever he said
but for a limited time period and this
will allow them of course to see what
happens well if there is disruption I
don't think that would be disruption
we've had very strong assurance we use
but you brought him into the
conversation in full yes what he said
but what what will happen on if we leave
on WTO terms you've heard
very very strong assurances from the
Dover Calot Dover Calais ports for
example both of them are saying there
will be no disruption - there will be no
queuing there made provision for the
extra checks that need to be made and
there will be very very few extra checks
made if any at all apart from the SPS
checks that are acquired under the
european community law you say this but
there is no other major player that
trades with the EU on purely WT arms WTO
terms do they know of Americans not the
Australians not the Israelis not the
Swiss the US has struck agreements all
the time with the EU and a very
significant portion of eu-us trade is
actually governed by technical
agreements isn't it well there's
technical agreements it will be odd if
the European Union doesn't make the same
kind of type of green agreements that
it's prepared to make with other
countries with whom it hasn't got a free
trade agreement if you're saying that
the EU is promising a punishment brexit
for the United Kingdom to put us in a
uniquely disadvantaged place compared to
everyone else I would say that's one of
the reasons why people voted to leave
you but the EU has the EU has procedures
it's not a common sense arrangement as
Britain's previous ambassador to the EU
pointed out some common sense
arrangement it's a legal order well that
I think that's partly if the EU is going
to be so doctrinaire as they would
damage their own trading relationships
with one of their biggest export markets
the United Kingdom that's one of the
reasons people want to leave the
European Union because it's an
inflexible and doctrinaire organisation
if your WTO breaks it is such a good
idea why aren't vast ways of British
industry recommending it after all their
sole aim is to be profitable and keep
the economy functioning isn't it well
there are quite significant
industrialists arguing for but more and
more companies are predicting damage
from breakfast against Tyson
JC Bamford these are these are companies
that would be perfectly happy for for us
to vote we heard yesterday two most
recent sir boardroom attitudes which was
the so-called boardroom bellwether
survey by the ICS a governance Institute
found that almost three quarters
of footsy 350 Company Secretaries we're
predicting their firms will be damaged
by brexit a sharp rise over the 42
percent who was saying the same thing
last summer
well I think they would say that
wouldn't they why how many of them I
remember the CBI and all those top
industrialists campaigning to be in the
Exchange Rate Mechanism at the end of
the 1980s and into the 1990s that cost
thousands hundreds of thousands of jobs
in the British economy said they've got
one thing wrong no they got the next
thing wrong they wanted to join the euro
they all said we had to join the euro
otherwise they would move investment out
of the United Kingdom they got that
wrong then they said if we voted to
leave just the vote would be enough to
drive the United Kingdom into recession
pay attention to the losers at all very
we've got rather worn out by the
doom-laden predictions of fat-cat
businessman who are concentrating on
keeping everything the same instead of
adapting to a democratic decision that's
been taken by the British people and is
going to be you talk about the people
responsible for getting the economy in
this country to run fat-cat businessmen
so yeah so you share Boris Johnson's
dismissive attitude to business where he
said screw business our country is not
run by big business big business has to
function without a democratic framework
and actually even though we didn't we
left the Exchange Rate Mechanism we
didn't join the euro we voted to leave
the European Union since that since the
vote that United Kingdom remains the
second largest destination for inward
investment of any country in the world
and headquarters have been brought to
this country by Chanel by Costa Coffee
the bowings going to open a new factory
new investments have been made in the
motor industry I don't sense that the
despair that some motor industry objects
a motor industry executives preach is
actually reflected in the decisions
they're making but this is a big gamble
I said in the end that you last summer
your colleague in the European research
group Jacob Riis MOG admitted as much
when he said we won't know the full
economic consequences for
very long time okay only enough that
wasn't on your campaign bus was it how
big a gamble is it then you tell me
opportunity he said is over the next 50
you says this is a big gamble tell me
how big the gamble is well in the end I
but what about the Bank of England
governor Mervyn King who said students
of economics looking back at the growth
of the British economy will be
hard-pressed to find the point at which
the United Kingdom left the EU because
of course your whole premise that you
are advancing is somehow uk's prosperity
is utterly dependent upon one
relationship that relationship we have
with the European Union in fact we've
been increasing our trade with the rest
of the world despite the fact we're not
in a single market relationship and you
have us the big promise from the if I
may just finish finished the point and
the trade we've done with the European
Union has been declining as a proportion
so since the single market came into
existence in 1993 we've grown exports to
the European Union by about 18 percent
we've grown exports to the rest of the
world by 70 percent how do we do it
we're trading on WTO terms of the rest
of the world were trading across customs
frontiers the fact is the future of the
United Kingdom does not depend on our
future prosperity not depend on
membership of the European Union the
European Union is the slow lane of the
developed world it's the high
unemployment high high regulation high
tax low growth part of the developed
world the rest of the world is growing
much faster than the European Union and
that's where our future lies and the
very premise is in the middle of a
slowed and every short-term trend we
should find which can't find every
pessimist usual tale these trends are
going to but you don't know what the
global economy is going to be right next
year you don't know what you don't know
if the European Union single currency is
going to last for another five years you
have no idea what's going to happen in
the future I said the fact is you don't
in this innovation dive in this global
economy know it none of us do this is a
big gamble well it's a gamble staying in
tell me about what the risks are staying
in we could finish up bailing out the
single currency again and if there's
another single currency crisis we could
find ourselves dragged into more
more centralized decision-making and
more and more centralized control by the
drinking the political discourse here
has turned bitter and confrontational
hasn't it well that's an example of it
well last year you said the Chancellor
and the governor of the Bank of England
you accused them of trashing the future
of the country as a propaganda exercise
yes
striking thing about your language you
don't just disagree with them you have
to impute the worst of all possible
motives to what they're doing knowing
that this kind of harsh accusatory
language is going to be picked up on
social media and used to get and
embellished this is is there a need to
talk about it in these terms well I
think there is a need to combat the
endless negative propaganda that somehow
this great country cannot cope unless
it's tied by an umbilical cord to its
European masters is it different is
negative propaganda well they have been
using very very strident and terrifying
forecasts there are actually scenarios
based on certain assumptions which
exclude for example what the government
would be likely to do if we leave the
European Union without a withdrawal but
it makes the debate an toxic to talk in
those terms cousins well I would say
there toxifying the debate by putting
out these scare stories which have so
far all proved to be untrue what's the
long-term effect of all this on the
politics here country is deeply divided
as we have them so other politicians I'd
say we have a very high functioning
political culture in this country and I
go back to the point we don't have a
rising right wing in this country
dancerettes and trolling and hateful
language I think have big uptick in that
since I think I think Reverend I think
the that's happened in other countries
that haven't had referendums are not
leaving the EU and the countries outside
the United State Office reported spikes
in hate crimes after certain events it's
such as the EU referred we just
concentrate on one country and identify
those problems with one issue leaving
the European Union when these things are
happening in other countries and
politics is polarizing the United States
it's polarized in other countries within
the EU perhaps much more
than in this country so why is that due
to brexit is the rise of the right
initially on Germany due to brexit come
on we just have a sensible political
debate about Britain here okay let's
talk about the United Kingdom what we
ran out of time so what will light the
fires of extremism in the United Kingdom
is if the politicians turn around to the
British people and say we said you were
going to take back control well you're
not the politicians are taking back
control and not not to keep Parliament
sovereign your country sovereign but
because we want to leave the power with
the European Union that is what will
lead to the kind of backlash in British
politics that we all want to avoid very
Jenkin good to have your own conflict
sir thank you thank you very much
[Music]